let's forget all the pieces on the
chessboard except one I've always wanted
to do this yeah we're going to focus on
the night for those unfamiliar with the
night it moves in a weird way it's like
an l-shape two squares by one or one by
two and it can do this in any direction
meaning that a night here for example
can move to any of these squares what I
want to discuss today is a puzzle called
the Knights tour and it involves moving
a knight around a chessboard using that
move but landing on each square once and
only once you start here there now this
is a puzzle that's intrigue
mathematicians for centuries including
none other than Leonard Euler you could
try it yourself or if you can't be
bothered keep watching and you'll see
here the Knights tour is indeed possible
and this one is one of the first ones
discovered here it is again but this
time I've numbered the moves you can
follow it all the way through
now you can probably see the final
square here number 64 can be joined with
the opening square number one using one
of the Knights l-shaped moves this means
this is sort of a loopable configuration
and we call this a closed tour
now here's another night's tour as we
watch you'll see when we get to the end
the endpoint here does not connect with
the start and this is called an open
tour now closed or open you'd think this
would be something that's pretty rare
right well it's not that closed to are
the first one we showed you there are 26
trillion different ways to do it on an 8
by 8 chessboard the open tour how many
of them do you think there are well it
turns out we don't know how many there
are and that's pretty mind-boggling but
if you think that's cool
here's something even cooler now you
might recall from previous numberphile
videos something called a Magic Square
little boxes like this where each row
column and diagonal add up to the same
number so can we perform a Knights tour
where those move numbers create a Magic
Square here on an 8 by 8 chessboard well
have a look at this one
seems pretty normal and here are the
numbers and have a look each column here
adds up to 260 as does each of the rows
and as if that's not enough have a look
at this each of these quadrants each of
the rows and columns in each of those
quadrants sums to 130 which is
interesting and as if that's not enough
each of these 2x2 sections some to 130
but alas this is not a truly magical
square because the diagonals do not
to add up to the required 260 this
square is what we call semi magical so
for a long time this was bit of a
mystery can you make a truly magical
night tour where the diagonals will also
give you the sums of the rows and the
columns and the answer is no you can't
it actually took a lot of computing time
but it's been done they've actually
crunched the numbers done the mole and
found out there is no totally magical
night store that can be performed on an
8x8 chess board but they did find a
hundred and forty different semi magical
tours where the rows and the columns
added up there are some brilliant
articles and research papers about the
Knights tour it's a really interesting
and active area of research in our
mathematics and computer science I'll
put some links in the video description
now while I start picking up these
pieces I will tell you we're going to
have some more videos about chess and
the numbers and mathematics behind it
coming very soon so subscribe to
numberphile that's the best way to keep
track of it or follow us on Facebook or
Twitter where I also keep everyone up to
date with what new videos are out but
also other stuff that's going on behind
the scenes